diese neue entdeckung eines
internationalen forschungsteams könnte
ganz neue anwendungsmöglichkeiten
eröffnen beispielsweise könnten hightech
materialien von computern und
smartphones enorm verbessert werden denn
fachleute aus spanien und den usa haben
jetzt ganz neue eigenschaften von licht
aufgespürt konkret können sie so
genanntes korkenzieher licht produzieren
dessen bahnen drehimpuls sich mit der
zeit verändert lichtstrahlen also die
eher einen korso als einen korken cnn
das licht dass diese eigenschaften
besitzt ist tatsächlich eine absolute
sensation klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt's täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen
eines zeigt am anfang mal klarzustellen
nicht ist nicht gleich licht erst wie
wir menschen durch unsere technischen
möglichkeiten mit dem licht umgehen und
seine eigenschaften manipulieren können
wir es als vielseitiges mittel zum zweck
nutzen
was ich damit meine die polarisation des
lichts beispielsweise wird durch die
schwingungs richtung beeinflusst die
energie und wellenlänge der strahlung
entscheidend dagegen über die lichtfarbe
auch wie sich die lichtteilchen photonen
bewegen ist entscheidenden laserstrahlen
beispielsweise geschieht dies im
gleichtakt eine weitere eigenschaft von
licht ist extrem spannend und zwar ist
vom sogenannten waren drehimpuls im
englischen orbiter angela momentum oem
die rede
in der fachsprache wird damit die
eigenschaft von licht bezeichnet die
besonders exotische strahl formen
hervorbringt die lichtwelle dreht sich
bei ihrer ausbreitung somit spiralig um
ihre eigene achse
dieses licht wird auch als korkenzieher
lich bezeichneten das macht seinem namen
alle ehre schließlich ist die rede von
einer schrauben förmigen welle ein
spanisches forschungsteam konnte jetzt
in experimenten beweisen dass sich
dieser wm variieren lässt werden sie
entdeckten und lichtstrahlen deren bahn
drehimpuls sich mit der zeit ändert dazu
heißt es in der aktuellen studie
im prinzip kann man sich diese
exotischen lichtimpulse als eine abfolge
von photonen vorstellen deren bahn
drehimpuls sie jeweils gegenüber dem
vorgänger erhöht
die metapher des korkenzieher soder der
schraube hat somit also ausgedient das
forschungsteam selbst vergleicht die
lichtstrahlen er mit der form eines
croissants es entsteht ein effekt den
die fachleute als safe torque bezeichnet
das bedeutet quasi so etwas wie selbst
verdrängung was tatsächlich auch schon
in anderen systemen der physik zu
beobachten ist beispielsweise in der
elektro dynamik und auch in der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie dennoch
die aktuelle entdeckung ist eine
sensation denn das auch nicht diese
eigenschaft besitzt war bislang
unbekannt
die entdeckung gelang dem spanischen
forschungsteam zunächst nur durch die
analyse theoretischer modelle später
dann aber auch der nachweis in der
praxis die modelle liegt nahe dass sich
r&m licht erzeugen lassen müsste dass
eine solche verändernde windows dichte
hat zudem ließen die modelle auch den
schluss zu auf welche art und weise der
self taught effekt nachzuweisen ist
möglich wird dieser nachweis nämlich
durch den sogenannten frequenz schirp
eine veränderung der frequenz im licht
korkenzieher denn dieser job umgewandelt
in hörbare frequenzen würde im
menschlichen gehör einen abfallenden
oder ansteigenden ton bedeuten
doch das alles ist viel einfacher gesagt
als getan dazu der us-forscher kevin
doch zunächst hat uns dies einiges
kopfzerbrechen bereitet denn schon das
oem licht zu erzeugen ist alles andere
als trivial
doch die experimente gelangen
tatsächlich die fachleute erzeugten zwei
strahlen von korkenzieher licht die sich
nur in einem bahn drehimpuls
unterschieden
durch deren überlagerungen in einer sich
über schallt schnell ausdehnen wolke aus
argon gas gelangen dem forschungsteam
der erfolg denn so entstand tatsächlich
licht mit safe torque strahlen von
energiereichen uv-licht charakterisiert
durch sich verändernde schrauben bindung
die änderung der bindungs dichte gelang
in der praxis also genau wie in den
theoretischen modellen vorhergesagt
durch die erzeugung eines veränderlichen
tons eine kleine sensation dazu die
verantwortlichen forscherin lori go das
ist das erste mal dass jemand diese neue
eigenschaften des lichts theoretisch
beschrieben und sogar beobachtet hat
damit haben wir demonstriert das licht
strahlen mit zeit ab
andré impuls erzeugt werden können somit
gelang es den fachleuten also eine neue
eigenschaft von nicht aufzuspüren und
das ganze ist nicht nur interessant für
die grundlagenphysik es eröffnen sich
auch neue spannende
anwendungsmöglichkeiten der materialien
und moleküle auf nano ebene könnten so
auf ihre dynamische struktur untersucht
werden interessant ist das vor allem im
hinblick auf hightech materialien für
smartphones und computer extrem
spannende aussichten für die zukunft in
die schaut ja doktor watson regelmäßig
und erklärt wie man nicht kontrollieren
kann unbedingt anklicken unbedingt
anschauen und unbedingt doktor watson
abonnieren es lohnt sich gar nicht nur
sagen bis dann bleibt dran